is the cleanup after the night before
they have been partying into the night
here in this small airshire village of
darville Aberdeen undone by this Village
a one-nil defeat a humiliating defeat
for the dawns last night here at this
football ground arguably as you said one
of the greatest shocks in Scottish
football history I think the context
here is absolutely key this is a
non-league team in the sixth tier of
Scottish Football a village with a
population of under 4 000 people and
these are also part-time players some of
them earning as little as 70 pounds a
week to play for darville as part of
this massive achievement that the guys
managed to do last night let's chat to a
very delighted manager I'm delighted to
see he joins us here at Michael Kennedy
Michael what a night for you guys a an
unbelievable occasion for the whole town
and the club in general it's when we
started this journey a few years ago
nobody
a couple of days for it all to become a
bit real and you know just when you come
to this football ground you get senses
to the community spirit this is not your
big club like Aberdeen that's what
really adds to the the shock Factor here
no clubs at this level at
community-based clubs very small real
Community backing the last part of what
we're trying to do every one of us right
at home the community something we can
bring the community together and that's
a massive part of success we wouldn't
survive without that support from a
local community and last night you seen
here they're coming out in the thousands
as you highlighted their population of
four thousand we're sold roughly two and
a half thousand tickets remarkable
achieving everyone connected and did you
genuinely think we're into that last
night that you had any chance of success
you know now that the game's over and
you've won what were you saying to the
team not from the drop from the first
thing the draw was made I was I was
always confident we won the game from
Monday all week of totally driven belief
through the group I was 100 in confident
we could have a cup up here upset last
night I know the quality within the
group and all the people who are in the
changing room and I knew everything
illness and they forcing the values that
we share within the club then I knew
that we could we could we could win the
game and what about
um the chat who scored the goal I mean
how is he feeling and what did you what
was that conversation like after the
game remarkable Jordan's played their
top level in this country as well he's
just worked his way down we're very
fortunate to have him and what an
occasion from what a night I just need
to try and find them somewhere in
Glasgow he was out last night after the
game all the parking sewer heads again
this morning thanks so much for your
time on Sky News uh this morning uh
Michael and yeah the parking will be
continuing in this very small
Ayrshire Village throughout the course
of the day and the mines will be
focusing on what comes next how does
this team build on the momentum of last
night but it has a massive achievement
that should not be understated teasing
Scottish Football